it's like your phone is basically a
terrorist that's trying to extort you
for money and so anytime you're on your
phone and you feel something someone's
making money yeah so of course here it
is that it's a tool that we need to use
because
well some of us do right some of us
don't we could always go off and live in
a yurt and have a different existence
that makes a lot of other kind of sense
yeah but if we're trying to integrate in
the world we need it but I mean imagine
like these phones are so dangerous in
certain ways if they're not controlled
it's like with our kids we almost are
seating to be like okay well you can
have a little bit of crack so that
you're not left out of everybody else is
doing crack all the time like we don't
want you to be excluded from the crack
Community
this is Jonathan Pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
all right so hello everybody I am very
happy to be here with Greg hurwitz Greg
has been on my channel before you you
might have seen him he's also I've been
involved with uh daily wire The Exodus
series that we're doing we've had great
conversations you might have also seen
the conversation between Greg myself and
and Jordan about Jordan's tweets and so
I would say that in the process of this
we are we're kind of progressively
becoming friends and discovering our
relationship like discovering the the
similarities and differences between our
position Greg comes from a more
democratic kind of let's say
left-leaning world but he's been really
great at Crossing Bridges and being able
to discuss things in ways that sometimes
it's hard to do so today I want to talk
especially about a new book that he a
new comic book that he put out called
new think in which he it's like a modern
fairy tale that deals with AI and and
some of the problems of technology so
I'm sure we'll Veer to all kinds of
things but uh but that's what at least
the beginning of the conversation so
Greg thanks for thanks for uh coming
it's good to see you Jonathan yeah it's
good to see you so so Greg gave me the a
copy of new think a while ago and uh I
went through it and I was really excited
to see first of all it's beautiful by
the way like the art is just really
beautiful there's something very poetic
about the way that you do the work and
the paneling it's almost non-linear in
terms of the way the panel is set up and
the the text you can read it you
actually create interesting ambiguity in
the way that you set up the the text in
the pages so that even if you could read
it in different ways but it would still
kind of bring you the thrust of the
narrative I thought that was very
fascinating but mostly what I what I was
fascinated by was
this this capacity to take fairy tale
tropes you know the vampire the this
kind of possessing agent right this
demon or something like that but then uh
frame it as frame it in the
technological world so first question is
yeah what is the thought process that
drove you into that that mode
well I was thinking about I mean there's
so much that's happening in our world
that is so utterly insane and it's like
we're like a frog being boiled one
degree at a time right and so I keep
thinking if we ported Us in for 20 years
ago
and sat us down in this moment of what's
Happening technologically it's just it's
bananas we can't even make sense of it I
mean I sent Jordan an email the other
day because we were talking about his
Rogan interview and I just pinged him I
said you know hey I just watched that on
3.5 acts and he was like 32. and I I
just said imagine back when we were when
you were my advisor if we were strolling
across you know college campus and
um and I said to you hey you know 20
years in the future
or 30 years in the future however long
it's been you know you're going to be
announcing like a new project for
Sovereign nations in Europe and you're
going to go on the website of a media
news demon who's a former mixed martial
arts fighter and professional comedian
who is the biggest news interviewer on
the planet and you're going to have an
exchange with him and I'm gonna ping you
and say that I watched The Exchange at
3.5 speed and you'll respond yeah me too
and there's gonna be nothing else we say
about it I mean it's utterly surreal
what we're living in right now in so
many ways
um and so I thought you know I've
written a lot of Thrillers fiction
horror um I've played around with a lot
of different forms and I thought it'd be
really fun to tell these kind of like
Black mirror-like Tales to have five of
them right the first one is a science
fiction Thriller the second one's a
fairy tale the third one is a kind of
vampire horror stalker Story the fourth
one is a time traveler story and the
fifth one's a children's tale like a a
children's story and I wanted to take
these tropes and kind of twist them
around so that I'm showing our reality
through just a different lens a
different kind of frame break and that's
something we do a lot in you know when
we talk about things politically and
culturally right is we if you want to
make people think differently you have
to break the frame on how we're viewing
our own situation and our own situation
now our reality is so surreal and so
bizarre that I don't even need to tell
stories that are actual science fiction
I could just tell our current reality
through different lens to show the
insanity so I did five stories like that
with five wonderful artists yeah and so
that it's interesting I think it's
interesting especially because like you
said
you're not you'd almost don't have to
show a dystopian future you're basically
representing something which is
happening now and you but you're just
framing it through narrative in order
for people to be able to see it
differently and that in some ways it's
almost it's different from Black Mirror
even because Black Mirror they've been
very prescient like they they kind of
just look that one step ahead and
they've been pretty good at it but
you're just showing us the reality now
that's right and trying to get people to
think about it differently I mean the
first story is called the screens
and I spell it with a k
um so that it sounds science fictiony
but it's screams it's computer screens
and basically I show how they came as
sort of a sentient being if you
described them that they came to earth
right and first they were like Giant and
corpulent and you know and there was
just a few and they were they were very
expensive and then through time we
basically worshiped them and then we
became enslaved by them right like they
got smaller and sleeker and thinner and
we got kind of more obese and more
disregulated right and we worship them
at our altars at home with our laptops
like the one I'm talking to you on now
and then we have we have these things we
carry with us all the time and right uh
we go to bed with them we wake up with
them they're monitoring our whole life
and we we carry them on our
transportation to work and then we sit
down at another Altar and then we deal
with that screen at that Altar and um we
basically are you know we're constantly
managing them and maintaining them and
updating them and finding patches for
them and making sure that they work and
so I just framed this as a story like if
you view our relationship with our
screens with our computers through
different lens they basically come to
Earth and enslaved us yeah but I mean
what's interesting about to me in that
particular video what was interesting uh
video I mean in a particular story
what's interesting to me is that I've
been you know for the last few years
I've been trying to talk with you know
cognitive scientists and different
people about the man in which agency
manifests itself you know and so like
also help people understand in some ways
what even the Ancients thought when they
used the word demon or the word Angel
you know this idea of transpersonal
agency that is coherent
and acts upon us and so and there's even
in terms of mythological thinking in
Christian the Christian world there's
this whole idea right you probably know
these Legends these these legends about
how uh
you know these Fallen Angels Came To
Earth and taught people technology and
then that brought about kind of
corruption and and uh and that's what's
led to the flood for example
um but I feel like today at least today
because we're seeing what's going on and
we we feel like we're not in control of
in and it's interesting because I saw it
with my own kids you know when I we were
homeschooling for a very long time and
when I finally put my kids in school the
first year my daughter I told her you
don't need a phone you know why why
would you have a phone like this is
ridiculous you're you know you're 13 you
don't need a phone and she's like Dad I
need a phone if I don't have a phone I
won't be able to do anything and we're
like no so so she didn't have a phone
for the first year she was in high
school and then we realized that we had
basically alienated her from every other
child and that she had no friends nobody
nobody talked to her she wouldn't nobody
wanted to see her because she just was
out of the system and then we had to
give her a phone if she was going to go
to school and then you realize that
you're not in control like exactly what
you show in your video that there's a
type of agency that is leading us and we
just kind of play along and if we don't
we get so excluded that we we can't
participate that's exactly right I mean
I've been through this you know with
with both my daughters in different ways
but my youngest daughter doesn't have
anything I mean she has a phone to text
but she herself got off Instagram
eventually but I mean the way I think
about this is it's like we all know
what's hap so look I'm powerless in the
face of it if I go on Twitter every day
if I'm on let's say I'm out on a book
tour and I'm so I'm checking like
reviews and where I'm supposed to be and
stuff I actually can see that my
attention span is getting fragmented
right so my own agency my own
intelligence such as it is my own
training
it's not better than uh teams of
addiction specialists hired by a social
media company backed by Deep machine
learning algorithms I can't overcome
that that's that's insane to think that
I can and they look you know when you're
scrolling on your phone or when you're
on a screen they can see they track like
your eyes like if you hitch on one tweet
a little bit or on one post let's say
they know where you're hitching to give
you more of that and so I just keep
thinking like imagine if I was in
seventh or eighth grade right I don't
even have myelination of my prefrontal
cortex yet and I'm being bombarded with
the most salacious possible gossip
that's designed algorithmically to
Target my anxiety outraged lust right to
keep me glued to that screen you know
it's like your phone is basically a
terrorist that's trying to extort you
for money and so anytime you're on your
phone and you feel something someone's
making money yeah so of course here it
is that it's a tool that we need to use
because
well some of us do right some of us
don't we could always go off and live in
a yurt and have a different existence
that makes a lot of other kind of sense
yeah but if we're trying to integrate in
the world we need it but I mean imagine
like these phones are so dangerous in
certain ways if they're not controlled
it's like with our kids we almost are
seating to be like okay well you can
have a little bit of crack so that
you're not left out of everybody else is
doing crack all the time like we don't
want you to be excluded from the crack
community so why don't you go on and
have a ton of images of other kids right
who are posting an idealized version of
themselves that you can look at this
fake version and then know that you're
not living up to it because it's fantasy
but you alone know that you're not yeah
so and my sister's a pediatric
gastroenterologist and she made an
amazing point about this because she's
in the Bay Area and she sees Kids all
the Time who are like I can't sleep I
have anxiety I have depression I'm not
eating and she goes give me your phone
and they give the phone and she goes oh
look you're on you're on your phone 11
hours a day right how often you're on
your phone they're like I don't know
like two three hours and you look on an
iPhone yeah and they're being eaten by
it and she also made a point that I
thought was quite brilliant where she
said you know it used to be let's say
you go home for the summer and let's say
two of your friends or acquaintances
went on a trip that summer together like
to a lake or to Hawaii if you get back
to school on you know in September when
school's back in and they say oh my God
we had so much fun you know at the beach
you feel really bad and then you go to
home room and then you go to recess and
you move on but now you're home and
every single day they're posting like
you're looking at these other kids where
you're not posting and what they're not
posting is the fight they got in or the
fact that there was a jellyfish sting or
the fact that someone was super passive
aggressive and they had a big fight or
that someone's boyfriend was mean or the
food sucked they're they're posing
they're posting these posed versions of
themselves and it's constantly in your
face this like sort of fake reality I
mean that's even before we get into the
filters yeah so how do we navigate that
without becoming like luddites right
because that's not going to be helpful
either if we like exclude our kids from
the modern world and so it's it's an
unbelievable challenge that I don't
think we've figured out the appropriate
ways to turn the dials on yeah
definitely and what's interesting is
like I said the the notion that it's
that it experienced as Agency on us to a
certain extent and it has its own logic
and its own kind of moving its feet in
the world that a good example is even
now my kids you know the same with my
youngest daughter we try to hold back
the phone as long as possible but then
the teachers give people their homework
in class
on their phones so if you don't have a
phone in class you can't even function
because the teacher is literally giving
the assignments and will give quizzes on
people's phones it's like so my man my
wife uh was a psychologist he's a
psychologist so she was in the field for
a lot of years which is great because
she was very practical she worked with
like child prostitutes
uh and Kids One Step before juvie and
then she went and taught so she had a
lot of clinical experience to bring to
bear and one of the things she would do
is is have the have her students get off
their phones for just a long weekend
four or five days and keep a journal
and they exploded they were sweating
some of the kids in her class didn't
know how to turn their phones off she
had one person whose wife was emailing
her because she thought that the he was
having an affair by not responding like
they lost their mind and the other thing
that happened is she had students who
were dating and what she wrote what they
realized was is whenever they had an
argument they couldn't have an argument
face to face so they'd have to leave and
then resolve their stuff over texting
right and so what was very interesting
for me about that is when we talk
uh and in particular if you've seen for
instance we have immunoglobulin B right
which is a great
um autoimmune booster like when we when
if you sing especially if you sing with
other people especially if it's in a
choir so here we are back to the sacred
it boosts it right it's a performance
yeah it boosts your your sort of immune
system as you're singing as you're using
your mouth as you're because our
tongue's wired to our brain is wired to
community and so as increasingly you see
kids kind of flatter of affect right
like we all have that story where we
sound like cranky old people we're like
these kids are so disaffected right like
they don't know how to express or make
eye contact but if your whole expression
is that your face is blank and you're
here and you're using a special language
that's designed right to make it easier
for the phones not for us or to make us
more malleable for the phones giant
laughy cryy face LOL and I've seen
people do that where they're deadpan LOL
rolling on the floor laughing right
and they're deadpan we're actually
moving off our evolutionary design
you're not moving our mouths we're not
we're not engaging right if you're in a
conversation with somebody you know
oxytocin is the bonding hormone right
it's a release and that that's not just
for uh intimate engagement where it
occurs right and not in
individual engagement let's just say but
it's also in conversation among friends
and so if you're talking and you have a
close relationship with your focused I
forget the amount of time but there's an
amount of time if you're sitting in in
you know a discussion or Fellowship
whatever you want to call it with close
friends there's a release that you get
of a bonding hormone right but if you
have a phone out and you check it every
so often you don't get that release and
part of that has to do with us checking
a close visual field far visual field
close visual field far visual field it's
triggering different parts of the brain
and so we can't settle into something
that actually derives
um feelings of of kind of bonding in
community but also yeah your mind is
also just split when you're doing that
if you're with friend but you've got
your phone and and every time you've got
a chance you just kind of check to see
what's what your notifications or
whatever and you are not there like you
are your attention split and it's also
weird because you think about this like
let's talk about this in mythological or
religious terms it's like we're not God
we're not supposed to have access to
every single thing every person in our
entire Community that's even unimagined
like oh that guy who I had you know I
was in Little League with and the girl I
had a crush with in fifth grade like oh
how's she feeling about her cat or
president Trump right now it's his
inundation right of information and
there's a sort of arrogance to think
that we can moderate and dip in to the
entirety of the world yeah of course
it's like you know again what are we
gonna do because we can have a
discussion you know when the print when
the the fabric looms were introduced for
instance
Austria's entire peasant class I think
this was in the 1800s was reliant on
making money with their hand stitching
so they just shut off they had an
authoritarian State and said no we're
not going to accept them right but
England hadn't integrated them and then
continued to go take over the world and
you know Austria kind of shriveled up so
we also can't stand in the way of that
and have like our own little like
Luddite Circle where we're we're removed
from the world in a way that we need to
engage and so it's a lot of what I've
been thinking about since our Exodus
seminar Jonathan because in particular I
think for me you have a way of talking
about faith and organized religion that
that really resonates with me because
um you pay so much attention to aspects
of The Fringe and how The Fringe
negotiates with the middle and what the
middle is right and a real openness
about the fact that in in any faith and
in or well certainly we were focusing in
this instance in judeo we'll call it
judeo-christian because we all know
where things are headed
um faith
that there's
an admonishment against too much
pureness like one of the things that was
so funny is we were talking about the
story of Miriam right who came in all
snotty pants about Moses when he wanted
to marry an Ethiopian and she was you
know clucking at him that he shouldn't
right it's too much Outsider right skin
color doesn't match
and in one of the the the great Strokes
of humor in the Old Testament God came
down and turned her Snow White it's like
oh you want to be pure you want to be
too pure how about if I make you glow
and now get out of the camp for seven
days so she's just like glowing
unappealing ridiculous version of too
much pureness yeah so there's this
negotiation
um which which you illuminated for me in
a way I didn't understand coming from my
world I think
well who knows what world I come from
but meaning a lot of people who are who
are let's call it tilting more liberal
have a view that that that if that
religion
only wants to impose sameness and only
wants to have exclusion right but here's
this clear admonishment to say too much
pureness right that's the monster of the
right like how dare you how dare you not
allow integration to new ideas
um and I was captivated also by the fact
that
um you know after Moses strikes the
stone twice
um oops and then gets excluded and his
entire generation is excluded from
entering the promised land also due to
some of the lying about what they saw in
Kanan the only two people of that
generation allowed to enter the promised
land are Joshua and Caleb and Caleb's
not an Israelite yeah it's like 50 of
the elders who enter the promised land
are foreigners right like why is that
right that's that's not a lesson of
ultimate purity
you're so right like that I mean the
story of Exodus is you can see it as a
mediation between let's say unity and
multiplicity and that's one of the
tracks that you can follow to see the
story of Exodus and if you do it that
way it's very powerful because you know
in some ways there's a there's an ad you
know it talks about the mixed multitudes
there's a few times where it mentioned
it uses that term and there's a sense in
which that's not good like you don't
want just that you just don't want just
a bunch of different people that coexist
together without any sense of unity but
then then there's a covenant that binds
them together and that actually makes
them participate but in that
participation there's different
differentiation and there's you know all
the the tribes continue to exist and and
the strangers also exist in the in the
land like Caleb says that Caleb Gets The
Fringe of the camp gets the outside of
the camp so he participates he's not
totally on the inside he is but he he
has that he has the Border let's say and
that you could imagine that that's like
a normal thing and in any any state like
if you had two empires the people on the
border would necessarily be mixed with
the other Empire like so they would get
the Border because they're not they're
kind of mixed and that's that's fine
that's how it kind of works you need you
need those buffers between identities in
order to to function so I I think that
that's
that's one of the places where I hope
that the conversation
let's say about how traditional
societies really function can avoid the
problem of the opposite right like you
said of of thinking that that tradition
is just like a kind of Purity and that
breaking tradition or modernity is just
about kind of shattering that but it's
it's traditional societies are quite a
way more organic than that in the actual
way they function well and you speak to
them to my mind with a lot of openness
and care about all these places and
that's that's rare like I think a lot of
people
um you know they're they don't unders
it's not like Faith it's not like
religion has been uncorrupted any more
than the rest of our institutions right
or captured politically
and so I think people have a sort of
pullback from any mention of it in a way
um the same way that other people will
if you talk about like a straight
secular higher education right or you're
you know HR department right or like all
these places that have gotten kind of
overlaiden in their own aspects some of
which of course there's there's
uncorrupt versions of everything Faith
included but what was so interesting for
me about that was it fits so much in a
lot of the thinking I've been doing
about kind of our culture which is we
have to have conservatives we also have
to have liberals and guess what that
bell curve of those traits and not to
detour too much but there's we have Big
Five personality traits that are
integral to us that determine very much
which way we sort of will lean on a
spectrum that can then be measured
politically and they're the same across
all Races and cultures it's not like
black people and brown people are
liberal they're they're not I mean one
of the big jokes uh in the 2020 election
was that Biden got the latinx vote and
Trump got the Latino vote right it's
like right it's it's not like it's not
like we divide into these personality
traits by the color of our skin yeah
there's a reason for both of them
whether whether one views that as
evolutionarily selected or god-given or
is that the same thing and part of that
is so that you know conservatives who
want to tilt more towards holding order
which is necessary right some in-group
favoritism right we need to build a wall
right and you think about that for when
let's say the Native Americans when
Europeans were coming towards them with
smallpox infused blankets like it made
sense to have a bit of distrust right
for an outsider but that but liberals
say wait a minute if you build a wall
and it's not porous and there's no
movement then we stagnate and die new
ideas and people can't get in and we
can't revivify ourselves culturally and
artistically we don't let in the
Grateful immigrant right we don't let in
the things that feed the culture itself
and so getting that balance right and
this is this is me getting back around
to what we're talking about with
technology I mean one of the things that
was really in some ways the most
compelling to me about Exodus was the
realization in some ways that that one
of the key aspects
one of the key roles that faith can play
when it is not corrupt or captured right
when it's embodied in people who are
really talking about it through a lens
of
um love and order right not just
overwhelming empathy not just
overwhelming judgment right but really
the integrated full Embrace without
hypocrisy is that it's one of the key
aspects of how we order our communities
you know and so the notion I had is
almost like you know faith in the in the
in this example or in this Frame that
we're discussing it's like it's the
conductor right that sets the sections
of a community in place and without it
all the sections are blaring
discordantly yeah right but it also
doesn't mean you don't want the
conductor to go sit down in the sections
and play the flute and play the trombone
and do all that that's not the
conductor's job either right you can't
have faith shot through all of society
because then everything becomes too
uniform and so part of me is thinking a
lot about the role that we need from all
of our communities to find the aspects
that are neither corrupt captured
ideologically right and how to bring
that Community into
harmonious relation which of course our
faith in our faith communities have to
play a big role in that and if we have
that all of a sudden we could set
different
parameters around technology to go hey
you know what maybe our kids in school
maybe everyone checks their phone at the
front at the front right they'll put
their phone in a box at the start of the
day and they get it back at the end of
the day well our communities aren't
harmonized sufficiently for us to like
we feel powerless to make that
discussion because there's so many
fights and arguments right and I think a
lot about you know with tick tock I'm
going to get some of the specific facts
wrong but um some of your viewers I'm
sure can can can correct or um update
this but you know tick tock
it's it's a it's a it's kind of like a
massive psyops operation right I mean
it's in from China they put all those
filters look I'm a bunny look I'm a
unicorn right it's capturing facial
recognition and in the U.S you know one
of the things that they've done in their
export is to lowers quick lower the
amount of time that each video will take
place so it's something like it used to
be 14 seconds then they lowered it to
12. now they lowered it to eight they're
just scissoring our kids focus and delay
of gratification and attention span and
ability to focus it's literally doing
that that's rewiring the prefrontal
cortex of our kids but in China
they're only allowed 20 minutes a day
and it has to be educational yeah like
at home they're eating broccoli and then
they're exporting heroin right and we're
letting it happen and we all know that
it's there you can read an article about
it but we can't get our communities and
our politics and our businesses together
to look at this and just go hang on a
minute right we it's like we've lost our
ability to reach a sane consensus about
certain things
um and that's what we got to get
together and that's a lot of what we're
trying to discuss in Exodus
and I think what's interesting though
about technology that's that's
fascinating because in some ways it kind
of raised the alarm in the sense that
one of the things that I try to help
people understand is that religion
ultimately in at the first stance has to
do with attention right that's what it
has to do with so it's it's worship
that's what it is and so
I think that for many people they don't
totally understand like why worship what
is this thing you get together and then
you sing songs you know you sing songs
to God and you all pray to God it's like
it seems flaky and ridiculous but the
idea is to understand that it's a
tension that binds us right common
attention is what binds us together and
so if we if we have if we're together
and we're focused on the same thing like
in a sports team for example then that
will bind us like we'll experience
togetherness in a way that is hard to
describe if you know that we're all
trying to score a goal in a soccer game
then all of a sudden it's like things
start to move together you start to be
aware of the other person without
thinking you know you make a past
without looking the person is there for
some reason it's like this magical
cohesion that happens as you're moving
towards a purpose but that has to do
with common attention so if we so
religion and Faith what it tries to do
is to identify what's the highest point
like what's the highest point of
attention what's the thing that can bind
us most
to the most together in the in the the
most important way and the highest way
and so you could say I mean a simple way
to say it's like if we all stand
together and worship the creator of the
universe who is also the god of love you
know who loves us and made us in His
image it's like maybe that would be the
highest point of attention that would
bind us towards and then things will
flow down from there and so one of the
things that's interesting about about
the the whole technology question and
the the capture of the screens that you
that you talk about a new thing is that
it's doing the opposite literally in the
algorithms right what it does is that it
identifies your idiosyncrasy and then it
feeds you more of that idiosyncrasy
because it's the most immediate way
common attention is hard right it's
difficult to work together towards a
purpose but like that little kick of
like get what you what you want in your
in your little private uh desires that's
easy to give you now if I can the more I
give you that then we're actually kind
of fragmenting ourselves of course I
mean you think about it like a 12 year
old boy with an internet connection
right now
has more sexual images at his disposal
than the in in a five minute surfing
through the internet than his
predecessors
generationally to the beginning of time
like a 12 year old boy's brain is not
designed for that that's like injecting
cocaine directly into the lizard brain
it's insane what that is right and you
know so we were there with with a good
friend who is a giant AI brain who who I
was joking is like Baby Hitler like we
just have to take him out now right
before he ends the world but then of
course the the answer is like well if
someone's gonna do it it's better if I
do it or else the wrong people are going
to do it like we're in this runaway
train situation but if you think about
it be we all know our silos we all know
our news sources but the opposite of it
you know with AI I think what's coming
with AI I don't think
I don't think secular society has the
answers for US unless it also thinks
symbolically yeah
one of the things one of the things you
I want you to bring up because you in
another discussion you had this
interesting point about Ai and how the
danger of AI devolving into individual
idiosyncrasy and how that at some point
can't hold maybe you can go through that
because I think it's very fascinating
well I mean so you're talking about this
with Faith right there's a higher
purpose that's that's binding people you
know whatever that means and let's say
that that there's versions of that in
secular society as well for people right
whether it's the Constitution whether
it's art when people are together
creating art when you're in a symphony
right and we can we can discuss like I
think there's a there's a reflection of
different light on those activities also
right so but we we need detour here well
even the fact that we all have cultural
markers that are the same right it's
like we it's like we know that Bach is
important Beethoven is important like we
we know that these works of literature
that we that we can read them and then
talk about it because we've all read
them so there's a kind of commonality of
attention that that holds us not at the
highest level but at a pretty high level
you know nonetheless right and even
Television right which came on and
everyone thought it was the plug-in drug
and it was gonna be the end of the world
and my parents did not let me watch
television when I was growing up because
they were convinced that it was you know
the end of any Focus
um but we used to have appointment
viewing everyone would wait to see like
next week like as a as a generation as a
community right you're waiting to see
you know what's going to happen with
Heather Locklear on the next episode of
Melrose Place like people were talking
about it things got revealed the last
time we really had that I think was Game
of Thrones in a significant way so
basically you know everyone used to wait
like what's the new episode what's gonna
happen next week right and when as soon
as we went to streaming it's like oh
this is so great right Netflix drops the
whole season I get everything at once I
don't have to wait but I can't talk to
almost anybody about any of the TV shows
that I'm watching aside from saying oh
I'm watching White Lotus season one and
they're like oh wait till you get to
season two well don't tell me anything
right I don't want spoiler alerts I
don't want to talk to you because I
don't know what you've seen and we're in
these different buckets already and it's
not like that's to our benefit you know
when I'm home sometimes I mean and I
click on Apple TV there's like a half a
trillion dollars worth of entertainment
on the TV but at times none of that
feels special it's like I have too much
access to too many things it's not like
I'm waiting for next summer when Return
of the Jedi is going to come out right
where I'm standing in line for four
hours to watch Tim Burt to get into Tim
Burton's Batman on opening up you know
and so we're fragmented so now with AI
let's take it one step further right
well I want my so my book series is
called orphanax right there's one book
that comes out every year everyone can
talk about it in my community I go out
on a book tour
well what happens with AI when everyone
can have their own version written for
them
right where they say well I want uh
orphan X book but I don't want any harsh
language and I don't want any threat to
children and I want to adjust the words
down to a
High School reading level and I wanted
30 shorter okay being there's your
orphanax and somebody else says well I
like I like the real violence I want it
more grotesque
um and I want it to be you know epic and
longer so there's theirs and there's
theirs and so you do the same thing with
music right and we start to do the same
thing with all of our AI interactions
we're doing a version of this with our
friends of who we're liking and unliking
right we're curating our relationships
we're curating our communities we're
getting rid of things we don't like what
if we say well I want to hear from my
uncle my crazy uncle
but I don't want to hear anything that
is his political views or anything
that's politically adjacent right so now
what comes in and it could be over taxed
over social media is my safe version I
think safe of him
I don't see him anymore like I don't I
we don't have meetings then I can almost
live in that illusion of my uncle and
it's fine like it's that's right and and
by the way I'm watching TV shows created
for me reading books created for me
there's news stories and this is what my
my friend was saying he's like we're on
the verge where we can write a different
news story let's say it's about the war
in Ukraine we that can be tailored
around the biases or outrage let's say
if it's for nefarious reasons if every
member of your family so all
five of your family members are reading
a different news story that hits their
trigger their emotional triggers
differently everyone's reading different
news and so all of a sudden we're like
in Wally the Pixar movie where we're
just kind of floating around ingesting
things right coming into our system and
our own little isolated bubbles well
that feels metaphorically a religious
speak that feels pretty distant from God
right it's like a vision of hell yeah no
that's a great image like it is a vision
of Health like you're alone and you're
in your own you're in a circle of your
own desires uh and you the the
the capacity you have to be with others
is being diminished diminished
diminished so to a point where you know
it's very difficult to engage with
people that aren't exactly exactly in
the same
lying as you right exactly almost like
little little mirror images of you we're
diminishing our ability to assimilate
and accommodate information which pajo
the great developmental psychologist
talked about that's the moderating
aspect of development right it's new
information what do you accommodate what
do you assimilate right what are things
that come in and we also we have no idea
what's good for us we have no idea
what's good news or bad news in the
short term there's a hundred Parables
about us right and we don't know if
something comes in that's traumatizing
that feels like the worst thing that
ever happened to us that three years
later you go well that's something that
fundamentally changed my life based on
my suffering who's going to choose awful
suffering for no reason up front if you
have a choice right so we're losing the
skills of like who knows when I like you
know it's it's
it's
challenging it's rewarding but
challenging for me to go have a
conversation with let's call it 10 of
the most
you know brilliant conservative Minds in
the Western World about religion you
know about the Old Testament it's it's
it's a it's a different kind of corner
of the universe where these ideas are
being and it's a range of ideas right
it's like Ben Shapiro's very different
than Oz Guinness it's very different
views very different from and there's
this kind of whole range of different
ideas and there's so much um where you
have to modulate between holding your
Center and accommodating new ideas and
having humility but remembering there's
a very firm disagreement with some
aspect of somebody's uh of thinking and
that's a skill that you're building and
we're not only diminishing our world
perception the worlds we live in we're
diminishing our ability to even contend
with difference in a way that is
Illuminating yeah and I think that
actually does explain why the Exodus
seminar is so popular
for the strangest like so so strange to
realize that this you know talk about
that man
talk about 16 hours about a book and not
get through it with a bunch of people
and people you know and like like 60 of
daily wire subscribers watch it uh and
so and so but I think it's because in
some ways like we are modeling you know
the possibility of what you're saying
the possibility of of difference coming
together or difference looking for
looking for
an honest recognition of things we can
see in common while recognizing the
difference you know and of course
sorry go ahead well and among our group
it's not like if we look at the totality
of each person there's plenty that I've
done that certain members of the group
wouldn't understand wouldn't approve of
doesn't match their value sad same for
me with some members of that group but
the point is is we're not going in
saying let's do a Godlike x-ray of every
single aspect of you and your conduct
right and then make judgment and figure
out who we're going to vote off the
island yeah what it is is we're going to
meet in a consensus in a kind of
Fellowship around one topic right and
everybody is going to be respectful in
their engagement of that TalkBack yeah
right but I'm not going to go back and
dig out a tweet from you know 15 years
ago where you like you know
insulted Hollywood
like you do like I do I think I think
you're referring to other people in our
group but that's okay
but yeah I think it's interesting I just
hope like I in some ways I hope that it
will be a model and not a like it's
that's the problem with media it's like
how can I say this it's it's I'm happy
we're doing it and I'm happy I'm doing
this but you could see how even
something like The Exodus semi seminar
could become like a fetishized
externalization of the need to do it
yourself it's like you watch it so you
get the satisfaction
of doing it right the satisfaction of
speaking with people and everything
without actually having to do it that's
the it's always the day here's my hope
here's my hope
um so I work with uh a woman called
Summer Ali who's uh who's a a brilliant
International mediator and international
right she helped mediate the Syrian
Civil War
um and one of the things she talks about
is how we're creating you can see when
we start to create an authorizing
environment for violence right and we
all know what that looks like right if
you if you if we turn on cable news and
choose your home team right language is
increasingly aggressive the other side
is increasingly a dehumanized monolith
right and then there's a lot of words
that are edging towards violence or or
towards the suggestion of Violence by
which I am not implying that words are
violence or that that should be shut
down or that we shouldn't have free
speech I'm suggesting none of that but I
think we understand as we're looking
that we've been creating an environment
where you know
uh cities can get burned down and one
people don't understand that we're the
husband of the speaker of the house can
get you know battered with a hammer and
people might make jokes about it like
we're we're inching into some pretty
uncomfortable territory and the solution
for this is to create an authorizing
environment for negotiation compromise
right civil disagreement opposing views
and so my hope is that you know one of
the things I wrote a book that takes
place in mind control Cults and I went
in and undercovered a mind control Cults
to research it and one of the principles
that mind control Cults operate by is
called pluralistic ignorance and that
means everybody's really unhappy but
since they can't share it with anybody
they don't say it or believe it they
think they're everybody's pretending
that they're that this is wonderful and
this is great because they see the
others pretending that this is wonderful
and this is great yeah and yeah and it
messes with your own perception so think
North Korea right like everyone's not
that delighted to have no electricity
and be starving to death right but they
can't say it there's no environment to
say as and if you speak out there's some
risk or danger obviously the risk and
danger and the courage that takes in
North Korea we're not holding a candle
to right for the fact that we're risking
what we call cancellation or kind of
outrage or reputational financial damage
but there's some of that right it's not
it's not a super easy Endeavor for a
bunch of people who think differently to
come together and do this but the hope
is that it creates an authorizing
environment
for people to see other sides of
different sides right there might be
some people you know the daily wire
subscribers are probably not going to be
as aligned with me on average for some
of my political views but ideally if
they see me there talking and engaging
in a different way there's an
understanding that we can have
negotiations and disagreements in ways
that are much more civil than we're
seeing in social media maybe in the
world and vice versa is the Hope and by
doing this and by trying to model
thinking and talking from kind of
different perspectives even as you and I
do you know in our friendship and in our
public engagements whether we're you
know like braiding Jordan for his tweets
you know um and braiding's the wrong
word right it's like it's like a loving
discussion about ways that he might be
able to more maximize the ability for
people to hear his wisdom is the fair
version but I like to just say braiding
for his tweet because it was really fun
but you know you hope that people can
see that modeled and it starts to create
an authorizing environment to say I want
to start saying what I think more I want
to start telling the truth more and I
don't have to scream somebody else down
because I can't possibly contain it
right my I'm so disregulated emotionally
I can't possibly talk to Jonathan paggio
because here's an interpretation of the
worst thing he's ever said and I can't
even comprehend it he must be
de-platformed he can't be listened to
right or with me and instead to
recognize that not just that but also
the ways we might be
um
prevaricating in our own communities to
kind of fit in because we really need
in-group protection right now it's
really not safe to not have an in-group
that's got your back right now and so
are there certain ways where you think
well this part's gone too far on the
right for too much Purity this thing's
gone too far for the left and too much
hybridization but I can't say anything
because I don't want to be those other
guys I'm not going to be that across I'm
going to just let that go and it's like
speaking truth right that's the that's
that's our sultanits in right like don't
say little lies all the time and so
we're trying to model that
um you know and and let's hope that
there's some measure of success and it
doesn't just piss people off yeah it's a
difficult I mean it's difficult to
navigate the things you're talking about
like if you if you try to try to I
always the way that I always analyze
things is I always try to apply it at
different levels in my mind so it's like
I think of let's say a family for
example and that you realize that you
know in a family if you want the family
to function
you have to you have to kind of let some
things go because it's the because it is
in some ways the inner group and you
also have to kind of iron over some of
the fleets like some of the things that
are that are complicated or else you
know it's gonna get stuck and it's gonna
not the wheel is not gonna keep turning
but then at some point that can become a
problem right you know if you have
serious
um
problematic patterns in your family and
you keep ironing them over and you keep
ignoring them and you keep kind of
wanting to to smooth it out so that
things function then then at some point
it can it can lead you into into disease
really into a disease pattern and so you
have to find that weird balance and it
has to do with in some ways with that
weird bound between something like rigor
and mercy something like you know uh
focus and and openness like if you it's
like a dance that you have to play so
that you don't you avoid the dangers of
of either because the thing about like
the thing about because sometimes when I
hear someone's like just say that tell
the truth it's like when I hear that I'm
like well and I know Jordan doesn't mean
that way because Jordan is is very
thoughtful about the way most of the
time he's very thoughtful about the way
that he tells the truth because he knows
that some truth can be said with a bad
intention right and you know that you
know that you know if you're in a couple
or in a family it's like you can say
things that are true but that the
purpose is still like the stab like you
could use the truth like a baseball bat
that's right exactly and so there's this
this there's this balance that happens
between and that and the thing about
that is like because we talk about
technology because we're kind of running
around that is that
there's a there's something about a
face-to-face encounter and they're
looking someone in the eyes that that
mediates that you know because the
problem a lot of the I see it because
I'm I'm the I fall into it too it's like
on Twitter for example you know it's
like you can say you just it's like
people's people coming after it happened
to me yesterday some guy coming after me
and I'm like dude this guy's been coming
after me for for months like he keeps
poking me poking me and then I just like
I lose it and I'm just like and I tweet
the thing and it's like like if he had
been in front of me and we had been kind
of arguing and it would get here your
moment like in traffic where you turn to
your wife and you're like stay in the
truck and you grab your like tire iron
and got out of the car it was like
exactly
that's going crazy yeah so see I
wouldn't like that that definitely
wouldn't happen and so that would be
because I would have to face the person
and then have to engage with them and
then he's like six foot eight and
there's like boobs right that's the real
reason but you know you don't say it but
but I'm just saying that there's
something about like you because you
mentioned something earlier where you
said uh these young young couples they
say young people that when they get into
a fight then they they can't deal with
each other they go back on their own and
they start texting each other in order
to to deal with it it's like man that's
it's such a scary spot because texts are
cold right they have that kind of
coldness to it whereas when you outdate
with someone there's a
like you feel it if you're if you love
the person you're talking to it's it's
if you're attentive to it what you'll
notice I mean at least I noticed it
myself is that like I get angry and then
I get angry and I kind of let it out a
bit a bit right and then but then I let
it out a bit but then because I love the
person all of a sudden like at the edge
of that I feel some compassion for them
and that's that's like something about a
fight which can sometimes be useful yeah
it's like you you let it out and then
it's like once you let it out you see
the effect of what you said on the other
and you're like oh man
okay so now I have to I have to reel it
back because I love that person and I
don't want although what I said is kind
of true and that's how I feel it's not
the extent of who I of what of our
relationship that's right unless you
double down right unless you double down
like the Pharaoh then you can just write
it all the way I Repent I don't and you
know it's really interesting you're
talking about brushing things under the
rug and there's also you know like one
of the things there's different
personality types how we come to things
right like you can also be too
confrontational right where everything's
a confrontation and so one of the things
that's so interesting
um for me it was so Illuminating to read
Exodus with with so many scholars and I
hadn't visited it in depth since
since high school really and and really
kind of any kind of depth but one of the
things is you know we're talking about
how the narrative structure like what
struck me coming from novels and and
screenplays and and such is just looking
at it it's like
there's so much attention that's paid in
in building this up as per into
procedural memory right that's the
memory if you get cracked in the head
and you lose your speech you still know
how to ride a bike it's the lowest level
of memory that you lose because it's
like here's what's gonna happen in the
story here's the story that just
happened this is sort of the structure
of a lot of the things right here's
here's what's going to happen and what's
coming here's the event that happened
and now we're going to describe the
event that just happened well for a
straight narrative story for screenplay
right everyone be falling asleep
um but that's not the point of course of
of
what the sort of sacred stories they're
telling they're teaching us how to push
it into procedural memory right
in Exodus there's so much of it that
becomes ritualized so right yeah like
the example it's like the Passover so
it's like here's what's gonna happen
right and Passover is the greatest it's
the greatest example because it says
like this is what's going to happen
before it happens this is what you're
gonna do right you're gonna eat the
bread this way you're gonna sacrifice
the animal you're gonna put the blood on
the lentils and then what you're doing
is so you remember what happened and
it's like whoa you know but you realize
just how much it has to do with
procedural memories like here's the
story here's what you're gonna do and
then this is going to be the way you
remember it like bodily by engaging in
it you know through the rest of the
through the rest of History basically
and so like compare that to Mission
Impossible action scene right like what
do they do they combine all of them into
one thing to keep the audience moving
right so it's like here's gonna be the
plan and as they describe it on the
Whiteboard you cut forward in time today
yeah keeping it as they're describing it
right we're not you don't want to tell
an audience those things okay so why is
it procedural memory well part of what
I've been thinking about
it's like it's asking us to be every
single character in every single story
so it's not like we all just get to be
Moses we're all also the pharaoh
right so when you're talking about
figuring out you know like do you sweep
too many things under the rug or are you
too confrontational right are you too
authoritarian are you too permissive
like we don't all just get to be Moses
we're also Aaron right we're also like
you know God comes down with his with
thundering Revelation with Moses and
Moses is like hey man I'll be right back
like don't do anything dumb and they're
like let's build a golden calf and have
orgies right it's like he's not even
around the corner yet and we're all of
those things right we're trying to
strive upward but we also are failing
and and if we try to really embody them
which is what procedural memory is it's
the embodiment of a story but we're all
the different characters and you know
that's also true
um when it comes to the gospels right
it's like we're all Judas we don't all
just get to be Jesus yeah everyone right
we're all the parts of that and all of
these Reflections and I think that's so
much of why it's shoving it into our
spinal cords the very manner that we're
saying is it's ritual it's like you're
all gonna fail you're all going to build
the golden calf and have proverbial
orgies or literal orgies I suppose you
know you're all gonna
but you have to constantly renegotiate
and figure out the different veils of
meaning and figure out the appropriate
levels as you try to progress ever and
perfectly upward right and we're all
going to have failings to hold things
together and we're not all going to
reach the ultimate ideal within our
lifetime and and we have to own a lot of
that and what's so interesting for me
there's a sort of comfort in that too
because it's like you know one of the
things I say is I'm I'm I'm liberal a
classical liberal right
um in a lot of ways well why is that
like part of That's genetics part of
That's My Big Five personality structure
like if I do the testing I'm like blown
wide open in openness like I'm as high
as you can test and openness that's a
very big liberal trait right I'm also an
artist
um and part of that's my environment
right then part of that's like there's
all these things and for so many aspects
like when I've delved into the culture
or into politics or into really an
exploration of things one of the things
that I realized is like I'm coming from
my own little lens right on the world
that's the result of my experience
genetics environment and personality
structure we all do and we all have
different lenses and all those different
lenses are what let us view the common
world if we're doing it in a way that's
more comprehensive as opposed to we have
our own lenses and we just feed them you
know those really cool shots in The
Matrix where it goes all the way around
in slow motion sequence like how they do
that is they set up a giant like Arc of
different cameras so that something's
being shot from every angle
simultaneously we all have these
different lenses and if we can integrate
them we get a very three-dimensionalized
view of a situation well guess what
that's how we navigate complex change in
the world as a culture right we can't
navigate it with this set of cameras
that are predominantly conservative or
this set of cameras that are primarily
liberal
whatever what do you think of what do
you think of like the theory that I I
tried to bring out I think I brought it
up quite a bit in the Exodus seminar
which is that ritual participation is
that's what it's doing so if you think
about a family meal is a good example
where you know the structure the actual
ritualization of the family meal is
creating outside of thought
the the balanced relationships between
the different types of people and the
different types of of possible human
interactions right so it's like we're
eating together there are certain things
we we know we have to do like you don't
make noise when you're eating you have
to be able to you have to like speak but
listen but you still have to finish your
meal so it's like all of this is being
being played together you don't want to
take too much food you want to leave
stuff from others you're checking to see
if everybody's got enough and so it's
like all this type of of of a of a very
embodied action right is is
structuring your the way in which you
should act more in a more let's say
intellectual or or a social in a looser
way right and that ultimately religious
rituals have it's not the only function
they have but one of the functions
that's what they have so like Sabbath
you know uh coming getting together on
Sunday worshiping together processions
all this stuff is is doing that for
people I don't know if you if how what
do you think about that well it's really
interesting and it's it's along the
lines of what I'm talking about a little
bit is
so that's really that's that's really
interesting so let's think about it this
way right like so that example I gave of
the Matrix right so let's say there's a
mini version of that at your table like
you're sitting around a dinner table and
you want to kind of accommodate the
reality and story of your family and how
your family exists in the culture within
all the perspectives and so when I was
describing me and all the things that
lead to me having or arriving more
naturally at a liberal mindset the more
that I approach any topic with humility
right and and I'm not suggesting I'm
good at this right but this is it's a
it's a it's a muscle we're always
building right that's different the more
that I become the more that I have a
three-dimensionalized version of
whatever the topic is and so there's a
lot of times where I'm like look I feel
like if I was the perfectly embodied
human if I had sufficient humility and
understanding in Grace
I'd be exactly 50 liberal and
conservative right that's the yin yang
and that sign line that the sine wave
between us is where you want to be
between Order and Chaos and the little
eyeballs are the kind of feat that's
Colossus of Rhodes standing astride that
and so it tends to be like I had a
really funny car I'll give you just a
quick example I had a really funny
conversation with a uh elected
um uh Republican congressman and we were
talking about like infrastructure and
Regulation and he said you know you
liberals think every time that we want
to roll back to regulations and so
because we want to dump toxins and
rivers and I just laughed and I was like
you're completely right that's exactly
what I think right every time that I
read a headline and it says like this
environmental regulations rolled back
I'm like it's just big business right
trying to like dump stuff and so you
know then I did an exploration with a
whole bunch of stuff and of course like
we do need some regulations but they're
way too overburdened and some are
ridiculous and some make sense like it's
way more nuanced than my little approach
it led to believe and so I think that
what we want to be eventually is all the
cameras that are filming Keanu Reeves
right doing his little limbo move we
want to be all the perspectives at our
table and in some ways the wisdom that
we want to embody or the grace I think
is the best word for it we want to
embody at our table is to under
understand and integrate all the
perspectives of the family right and use
kind of minimal possible force and have
the discussion and the influence be
freely entered into per Oz is freely
entered into Covenant right and the more
that we can embody the more views
it's like it's all the same thing right
we don't get to read a gospel and be
like hey I'm just going to be Jesus I'm
not going to be Judas in my reading of
this story I'm because that's just
that's just how I identify it's like I
don't care how you identify right you
don't get to just be Moses and not be
the Pharaoh if you're reading a story
and paying attention you don't just get
to be you and not your daughter you
don't just get to be you and not your
wife's perspective yeah but you can't
lose yourself into that either so how do
you hold your lens and understand all of
the lenses and when we do that we have
an integration
right of all the Mosaic pieces that we
can step back from our natural
proclivities but also Behold a bigger
picture and that bigger picture is what
helps us navigate towards health or
Prosperity or at least towards the least
awful misery when when suffering arises
yeah so
I mean I
I think that
the reason why I brought up the meal is
that what I'm trying to push for is I'm
trying to push for the idea that
if you talk about procedural memory and
procedural
you know procedural participation
there's a sense in which there's a lower
aspect to this like a more grounded
aspect but is what I think ultimately is
looking up higher which is something
like
if you know how to pass and this it's
going to sound boring when I say it but
it's like if you know to pass food down
the table
right and if you know to be watching
other people's glasses to make sure that
they've got enough water enough wine or
or whatever if you have that attention
which is very grounded and that you know
you you you you're attentive enough to
make sure that everybody gets a little
chance to speak even before
the content of what we're saying that
there is a embodied procedural reality
that's ritualized that that makes it
possible for the other part and that
because what I'm trying to help people
understand it's like I'm really trying
to help secular people understand
religious ritual like why religious
ritual is useful and so the idea is that
because you mentioned it before like if
we stand together and we sing together
right in a choir for example and that
especially in a choir where they say
you're in a choir and you've got
different voices and everybody kind of
has to follow their voice and then but
also be attentive to the other voice
because you want to stay in line with
what the others are singing did that
that behavior doing that practicing that
will make it easier for you
to then scale that up into the meaning
like the actual explicit meaning world
where where you can then discuss with
someone but it it's actually grounded in
a deeper thing like it could it could be
other other things like playing a sport
together you know that kind of thing
playing games together if you play games
together then all of a sudden you
there's a kind of
there's a kind of ethic of the game
which is it's not political it's not
ideological there's nothing about it but
if you embody the ethic of the game it
puts you in a space where you're able
then
it trains you to to be able to interact
with others and it trains you also for
the Transcendent right so what do we say
when you know Michael Jordan's Michael
jordaning were like God he was out of
his head today
he's not he's not him right all the we
have so many phrases with that with
sports and like watch you know watch any
baseball player step into the Batters
box if we want to see all the ritual all
the things that they have to do to get
embodied in a particular space right
there's so many cues before you're gonna
step in and engage in a game which then
needs to proceed in a certain way that's
harmonious
um no I think that's I think that that's
right and if we don't if we don't set
those cues right like I remember
I had these I had double hip surgery
about like eight nine years ago and so I
was going like as part of rehab like a
year in I was starting to go to yoga
which now I love I do like you know Hot
Yoga 110 degrees and whatever but you
know it's not like I was good at it it
wasn't anything that was natural but it
was really funny because I was like
working when I first was going and I'd
go driving down there and I'd get like
all aggravated if somebody was taking
water in front of me in line right like
everyone hurry you know I gotta get in
and do yoga and be like embodied and
relax like what are all these people
inconveniencing me right and so there's
this funny thing that to like to catch
it and laugh at yourself and be like
right everything that you're doing right
is trying to set a template so of course
that's ridiculous right so how do you
how do you set your system down before
you go to the gym talk to your wife
right go online right like anything that
we do we want to get into a space that
we're oriented towards where there's
some sort of ritual and engagement where
we're clear of mind that we're bringing
the right part of ourselves to that
endeavor right the most valuable thing
you're talking about attention the most
valuable thing we have is our attention
and where we put it like we we are
literally where we choose to put our
attention
you know and so what you're saying about
dinner is it's like do we all set the
table right you how do we how do we come
to this right where there's already a
bit of choreography that is ritualized
right that starts to set the mood for
whatever the discussion is to come
um and can help people I think that
understand this can help people
understand also the important for
example of holidays right why why it is
it why for example
like why it would be important I'm not
American but why it would be important
to have a national holiday and why we
have to celebrate that with things that
are in some ways apolitical
right apolitical in the direct sense
it's like it's like there's a flag
there's uh there's just you know a
parade there's a potluck there's
whatever it is that that sets a kind of
a ritual space of participation in
something which binds us which is
something like our nation uh and that
and that avoids when we try to like when
we politicize holidays for example too
much then it it can't do that like it it
tends it right whichever way you you end
up doing it it can do that because it's
like you're not in the right embodied
procedural space that you should be to
create that that ritualized uh
participation that's right and what
we've seen with the elevation and in
some ways I think this is with the you
know the the
leeching out of Faith from society is
that politics has filled that void
right and you know
I don't have a great explanation for it
because like you can't just like Rush
people into faith and it's like people
have a ton of trust in the religious
institutions from the secular World any
more than people in the religious
institutions have a lot of trust in the
secular world and what's happening you
know it's like but everyone's got to
come back to the table and Stitch
together but what we've seen I see this
so much in the Arts right it's like
for me there's a very clear value
structure when I'm writing and it's like
art
politics if you flip them you're doing
propaganda yeah right so I've helped
politically I've written speeches and
commercials for candidates or people or
causes that I agree with but I'm very
clear when I'm doing that that doesn't
come into the books or screenplays or
comics and if you subvert it and if I'm
if I'm pretending to tell you a story
but I'm really indoctrinating you just a
little bit in ideology you're going to
get angry and rightly so because that's
not why you're coming to read a comic or
a book or many people some people just
want to read propaganda they want to be
put in their little Wally seed right
yeah for sure it's it's easier to read
the propaganda that you agree with and
so you know it's it you don't notice it
as much but we should still be careful
because you know
it doesn't have and it's good that you
bring up storytelling right and because
storytelling also if you have proper
storytelling it is it is it does end up
being not in the not in the
argumentative State not in the state of
of uh of dialectic let's say but it's in
it's in the state of procedural
relationships and so you follow a
character through events in their lives
and you identify with them and then you
you're challenged or all of this that's
that that's something that is has a
universal quality they can help us then
train ourselves for the for the other
stuff but you're right I mean you can
see it that's why I mean that's why
right now it's
I mean so so many of the movies and so
so much of the media has been captured
and it's very difficult
I mean it's it's difficult because it is
siloing us
you know I have a friend who's who's
conservative
um
pretty conservative right he said
something really funny he was like look
in terms of watching the Oscars or
something he's like I don't want to turn
on the TV and watch a bunch of people
tell me how stupid I am like right it's
it's
you we need to have and part of this in
some ways is it's like
I I don't want to take my politics and
moral leadership from artists I want to
take like Wonder and awe and contrast
and shock and surprise right and and be
Jarred into ways of thinking from some
chaotic Vision right I don't want to
read Faulkner and figure out then you
know how to think like Faulkner writes
about race in America it's just
unbelievable right Southern Southern
writer he's just so nuanced it's so like
spectacular just feels like it's turning
your brain inside out you know or you
read Richard Wright you know like you're
re when you're reading real art
it's it it shouldn't be neat Solutions
and I think part of that is a loss of
sacred rituals I'm gonna expand the term
a little bit but for me it's when I'm
writing I'm trying to engage and you
know I think for you obviously when
you're carving
um
obviously your subject matter is also
more more specifically or more closely
aligned with the sacred but you
we have to hold those spaces in other
ways like I have to have my writing or
my art as something that's sacred that's
said above everything else if I subvert
it to the political right if I subvert
it too much to the commercial
right
it doesn't work it becomes something
else than what it's supposed to be and
so in a world where we're kind of
denigrating
hierarchies right with some haphazard
and where everything's political all
things are political yeah we're we're
losing the different aspects of our
society that actually anchor at like the
Arts should speak differently to
politics like or or it should have a
different place in the conversation
right than politics do education should
have a different place than politics do
Faith should have a different place than
politics too but if we see schools
embodying ideology if we see you know
Faith communities becoming overtly
politicized with one side if we see art
and entertainment in Hollywood start to
get hide Bound ideologically in a
different direction all of a sudden it's
everywhere we look and it's just it's a
capture because I think that's the
easiest lever
Force for the hate industrial complex
right cable news fundraising letters
from politicians
um social media that's the easiest lever
for outrage and Terror and fear to have
us just hit and be glued to if we can
turn everything about that right
did this movie do the wrong thing
politically right it's it's just hitting
the lever did this person do this or
were using you know do you have the
proper stove are you adhering to the
right regulations you right did the
right movie get this award if we can
turn everything into that it's a
constant churn of judgment and hate and
outrage and insecurity and Terror and
also there's a real Pride to it too
because then we all feel like we've cast
ourselves in this immensely virtuous
role in some moral pageant right where
we're all you know standing forth
against the inequities of the ages or
you know we're the last voice against
mouth-breathing reprobate seeking to
tear apart the fabric of society on the
other side that's a terrifying monolith
that can't be distinguished and in
reality it's like dude you're tweeting
you're not doing anything special right
you're tweeting into a void and you're
probably talking to a bunch of Saint
Petersburg troll Farms right or like you
know it's we're not doing what we think
we're doing we're engaging in a fake
dance with the fake intelligence yeah
yeah and I think that that's why in some
ways I you know when I tell people
there's a catchphrase I say people I say
go to church and what I mean by that is
in some ways it's you have to engage in
the human relationships around you
that's like the best way to go about
that you know you have
you have relationship do you have a
family you have some kind of community
around you and so that's the the best
place to go because
in some ways that's the place that
will have this procedural aspect to it
that will will ground the other stuff
you know it's like if you have to if you
have to you know to help your kids with
their homework or you have to do this
this kind of really grounded stuff that
has nothing that's very little to do
with the ideology you you get engaged in
others other people's lives then it that
it binds you in a different way right it
binds you in a way and you can't
Outsource that you know it's like
like one of the things I say sometimes
is the luxury will be the death of us
right it's like you could hire someone
to go teach your kids coach your kids
soccer games right you could have
someone else do that like we could
always be way too busy with our own
lives than to do the stuff that's the
real bonding and then it's not even just
that you're coaching your kid at soccer
it's that you're driving them right and
then you have that car time that you're
not looking at each other so there's
more information and you're driving them
and their teammates and when they're in
the back they're talking differently and
you get a different you know view of
that and then there's kind of discipline
and there's different rules that you
engage with on the field and then
there's different celebrations through
like there's so much stuff to it versus
being like well I'm busy so someone else
can do that you lose all of that texture
yeah yeah and it's tempting I mean I
imagine for you for me for sure because
there's so much pulling like it's so
much pulling there's so much to do like
you could just there's so many
opportunities and it's like yeah you
gotta be careful family don't bother me
I'm carving Jesus leave me alone yeah I
mean like what like what do I know it's
like
it's interesting when you talk about
this with Community though because one
of the things I think that
um
I've been fortunate about is
I've always moved between really
actually diverse communities not in like
the modern sense of it but like I've so
many different communities or friends
with really really differing viewpoints
you know and that's that's challenging
it's not it's not it didn't used to be
as challenging as it is now because
there's so much distrust
you know but like learning to really
negotiate that to really try to to
understand and see like you talked about
when you get angry in your family and
then you let anger out but then you see
the effect it has right and then you
have to pull back it's like if you're
doing that in different communities or
different groups especially in this
environment where we're so where there's
so much distrust and there's so much
tribalism it's pretty um
it's amazing because it really
for me I feel so much
um
kind of
undeniable reality to not turn any one
group of people into a monolith because
once you turn people into a monolith you
dehumanize them so you can talk about
well the regressive left right or the
resentful right
but it's like there's so much Nuance
everywhere and if you're in real
relation with people with really
differing views like you know look
Jordan I've been friends a long time I
mean it's been more than half my life at
this point so many people are like you
know here's what a tweet he said like
how could you be friends with him right
how could you not and it's like well
like you think you disagree with him we
have tons of disagreements right some of
them even public I always think like
imagine being so limited in the scope of
your imagination that you think that
you'd want to be friends with Jordan
Peterson and agree with him on
everything
what like why would I want to have a
relationship with you to try and like
win you into my full set of views rather
than having an engagement right it's
like there's so many things to learn and
figure out and see differently and to
hold the respect that we all come from
different
viewpoints Big Five personality traits
genetics experience and to really try to
embody that to try and listen and you
know that's so much of what we're doing
when we engage with story like we're
taking our nervous systems we're trying
to listen and take our nervous systems
out for a test run we don't have to be
the ones who get eaten by a bear right
or nailed to a cross like we we get to
try to experience this and see what it
is and and parts of being in community
are that way too and if we lose that
muscle to want to really understand and
embody what somebody said the other
thing is is that it requires it a lot of
security
to be able to contain your own emotion
about whatever political
polarizing opinions you come from to
really open up and let another
perspective come in and come through
yeah you know and Carl Rogers talked
about that the psychologist he's the one
who you know he was the one everyone
makes fun of of like well how did that
make you feel right that he's that
psychologist but he's you know one of
the things he did was he sat patients up
like Freud would sit you know with his
beard in his pipe and then the patient
would be laying on a couch and he was
sort of sitting and they weren't facing
each other Rogers sat him up you're
sitting face to face you're looking at
somebody and one of the things he did
was he talked about how
like to really listen you have to embody
with empathy in your nervous system
almost like what is being told but then
you have to have security you're not
going to lose yourself right and all of
a sudden come out and be like I'm not
going to come out of Exodus all of a
sudden become like a you know
Christian Warrior for the right which is
like a fear that a lot of people would
have for
for that Venture yeah yeah they're like
what are you doing like what are you
doing over there and it's like look it's
amazing like if I have a chance to sit
down and talk with Oz Guinness at length
that's amazing right do I want to resist
that to get as little as I possibly can
to make sure I'm always leading with
everything that I think first
no if I can open up to his perspective
in a way that then is shared or that he
opens up to my perspective in a way he's
so winning Oz right that it's it's hard
to not be engaged with him yeah for sure
yeah but if you have that relationship
it's like there's so much
um kind of richness and then you can go
away and figure out your accommodation
assimilation right and then it's you
know it's hard moving between
communities right now you know it's like
re-entry can be hard moving one
kind of culture and Community back to
another but it's so worth it it's so
worth that
so I wanna I wanna bring you because
right now you just you're gonna leave on
tour for your new orphan Xbox all right
and so one of the things that I found
interesting about that is you know we
were talking about Ai and the problem of
this idiosyncratic novel and uh and you
also have a way with or for next like
you you have a charity that is related
to orphanax that is kind of trying to
connect into the world so I'd love you
to just talk a little bit about that
because I think it is an interesting way
because sometimes like we talk about Ai
and like the danger of it coming like we
shouldn't we shouldn't what do we do and
so I think that you found some
interesting ways to connect your
literary work into the real world to
give people the sense of participation
in community and something that's more
than just a novel right so look as we
were talking about that I mean really
over these last weeks as we're thinking
about this fragmentation with AI you
know one of the things that occurred to
me was
you know I want to have part of what is
going to be
special or worthwhile about this about
my writing about me as a novelist if
pretty soon we can have ai write novels
it's like we can have arguments about
the spark of the of the Divine in humans
right like there's a human governing
aspect to for when you create a novel or
a series of novels
but I think in some ways the thing
that's the most important that's at the
bottom of it I mean it's it's really
obvious in a lot of ways but it's
Community it's the fact that everybody
reads the same book right I write one
orphanax book a year and the books are
really about I mean orphan X for those
of you who haven't read it you know he's
a
he was taken out of a foster home at the
age of 12 as like a very unwanted member
of humanity and trained to be an
assassin an off the books assassin for
the US government he was trained up
basically to be an Expendable weapon and
one of the things that his Handler his a
CIA Handler who raises him kind of an
isolation and puts him through very very
rigorous testing
um and training but he tells them early
on and he actually really loves Evan and
that's one of the things that's a bit
different about this isn't just that
he's trained it's traumatic and awful
it's also the best thing that ever
happened to him because it's the first
time somebody treated him with love and
care but so Jack Johns who's uh
orphanax's Handler and Father Figure
orphanax's name is Evan smoke he says to
him when he's 12. the hard part isn't
going to be turning you to a killer the
hard part is going to be keeping you
human
and so the series is very much about his
process of being trained under these he
has like the Assassin's Ten Commandments
right that he's never supposed to break
but it's very much about the process of
him shattering through into a different
understanding of one of the things I say
is he never learned the strange language
of intimacy it's almost like he's
Pinocchio and he wants to be a real boy
and so it's the process of his becoming
it's the process of him learning to be
human in a lot of ways and so the thing
that's the most I think important about
this is that everyone's not reading
um a different storyline that's designed
just for them once a year everybody can
read the same story that comes out and
that's that's what a fan base is that's
what readers are that's what community
is that's who shows up when I'm on book
tour we're all there
um to talk about and discuss one Arc
that's happening but one of the other
things that that happens that I set up
is that orphanax as you mentioned uh
there's there's a charity so he
basically left the program it's called
The Orphan program at some point because
those two things being human and being a
killer are like trains on a collision
course and he essentially becomes a pro
bono assassin like so he can align it
with his own moral compass he's got
unlimited resources he's got an insane
skill set and basically he will help
people who were being terrorized by
other humans who have nowhere to turn
and there's no way the law can protect
them and so he has an encrypted line uh
phone number it's one eight five five to
nowhere and if you you can call it and
you can see if he answers it in the real
world and every time he answers that
phone he says do you need my help
and so I started a foundation called the
junior my help Foundation where we go
into local communities we don't
assassinate people I hope
[Laughter]
depends who Pago that's right that's
right
um but basically you know I I do I do a
lot of democracy unit and unity building
work
um uh pro bono and so one of the things
that we do is we go into
um through through uh organization uh
called millions of conversations I
mentioned my the partner I work with in
that uh whose name is Summer Ali who
started it and we go into really left
behind counties in a program and build
kind of community leaders to then have
them figure out what problems they want
to solve and then we bring in experts in
you know rural Economic Development and
mediation to try and help them out of it
and so really what it is is we're trying
to teach them to fish again right in
this new world where everything has
conspired to leave them behind but one
of the things is is while you're
teaching someone a fish you also need to
give them fish right or they're and so
do you need my help is something that I
set up that's just a stop gap for some
of those things where it's like you know
we had one family in the first place we
went was in a Grundy County that's the
most uh it's the poorest count in
Tennessee
um and when we went there I went there
two weeks before the midterm elections
and nobody mentioned
Donald Trump or Joe Biden or midterms or
January 6 or China or immigration all
that they were talking about was I don't
have enough gas in my car to drive 35
miles to talk to Social Services to get
food stamps to feed my kid like the
problems they're dealing with were so
concrete that there's no room for all
the stuff that we're screaming about on
CNN and Fox News and so there was for
instance one of the first uh the first
kind of Grant we made was there was a
couple there young couple his car broke
down there's no public transportation
right the roads are terrible
um his car broke down he lost his job
because he couldn't drive to work his
landlord kicked him out they had a
newborn baby who developed a respiratory
infection
um
and the landlord poured bleach all over
their possessions as kind of Revenge for
them not paying the rent so there's this
young couple with a newborn who who've
always worked right he's always worked
up until now who are literally out on
the streets and then you get into all
these regulations right and issues so
there's local charities who were there
but all of their funding can't go
towards kind of this relief in this
particular example like they can pay for
certain different programs but there's
there was nothing there where the money
had been earmarked to help them so we
just stepped in and got them a a motel
room for three weeks while the task
force scrambled on the ground there and
eventually got them a place in uh longer
term housing that didn't open up yet but
they would have been homeless right got
the baby Medical Care gave them a base
so they had somewhere to sleep and then
they got moved into longer-term care or
longer term housing and then the husband
applied for a job in the military right
and then needed some help because he
failed the math part so we have somebody
who's a military veteran who's amazing
who's one of the founders of millions
conversations and so we can point them
to resources and so it's just sort of
like when when when this little family
kind of fell off the curb into the
gutter it's just this little assist to
pick them up and put them back on the
curb again right and there's there's
other stuff we have like a bunch of
floods destroyed
um schools in Tennessee and one of the
schools just got wiped out and we're
going to go in and just put in like a
rural computer lab I'm sorry a computer
lab for this Rural High School right
that lost all of that for the students
so we're trying to go in while while
this longer action plan is kind of being
built up and that's called Genie by help
foundation so that the readers and the
community of orphanax readers can also
kind of participate
um yeah and also then the cycle of
Charity and gratitude stays in the
community right it's it's given by and
chosen by the task force not by me right
not by me outside the community right so
that everything stays within there and
so it's just another way to try and
Stitch this community together around
the story and the story ultimately is
about helping people though of course
it's a thriller so he's you know
executed killing people but I mean in
some ways it I mean I love it because
you're you're trying I mean I don't know
how consciously you're doing it but
basically you set up a narrative that is
of course extreme because it's in the
story world it's about assassins about
this but then you set up a structure and
then you're trying to help that
structure inspire people
and giving them a path for it to inspire
people into their real life because I
mean the problem of entertainment is
often that it can be it can just be a uh
a supplement or it can just replace
actual virtuous action right so it's
like okay I watch movies about great
figures that did things that are that
are inspiring and then I can just go
back and go back to sleep yeah you know
where else we found that in a study is
that's also what angry political
tweeting does yeah yeah yeah I did my
part today boy I really told them off
that's right and you go back to work and
it's like
um right beneath you screaming at your
hated politician or celebrity of choice
like what's the cause you're real you're
really worried about if you can peel
back all the layers of performative
outrage that you're trying to help right
do you really care about like what's
happening at the border or immigration
or like you know how are you trying to
fix that from whatever side you're
coming from right like what's the ACT
action that you're doing and you're
right we can sometimes just be blowing
off off steam but you know with
storytelling and I've always thought in
stories like a lot of that is Trend
challenge myself really because I'm not
I don't always know what the characters
are going to do I don't know how things
will turn out I'm not just filling in
the blanks when I'm writing the story so
it's trying to be about kind of growth
out of the chaotic some organization
into some new version of of order but
the more that I can have that Community
around me both online and there's a good
use of online like when I'm online I try
and be about the books and stories and
joy and reading and right it's a there
that's a nice way to have an established
online community and use social media at
least for me and when I'm on tour seeing
people who show up right who are
interested in talking about ideas or
interested in talking about orphanax and
then trying to do a bit of good in these
communities while also deferring to and
having humility that the communities
will know how to help themselves better
than I will right we need to go get the
local we need to get the ground truth in
those communities to choose where to put
those resources right I can't just come
in from the outside and say I've
determined everybody needs education
it's like what like where you've been
the last 40 years while we were on a
slow downhill slide because everyone was
ignoring us yeah
so so so what's the name what's the name
of the the new book and tell people
where they can if you are in tour tell
them if they can come see you somewhere
oh I'd love I'd love people to show up
so it's called the last orphan
um and people can find me my website's
Greg hurwitz.net
um you can find me on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram and I'm going to
be in London I'm going to be uh Northern
California I'm gonna be in La I'm gonna
be in all across Texas Austin Dallas
Houston I'm doing an event in Fort Myers
I'm doing uh I'm gonna be in Tucson and
Scottsdale
so it's a lot of travel that the tour
stuff is is all on my uh website if you
want to come look for it and if anyone
wants to come say hi and and talk story
or or you know orientation towards
towards meaning or order or anything
else
um you know everyone's welcome it's a
they're they're a lot of fun I love
going on tour cool well and everybody
check out new think I really enjoyed it
for sure and I think like I mean if for
people that have people that have
followed my work you know some of the
stories like at least two or three I
would say three of them in of the of the
total really just connect right to the
kind of things that I that I talk about
that I care about so so Greg thanks man
this is as usual we could this is great
and I hope we see each other at if we're
gonna do uh some kind because we
everybody people don't know we finished
the second part of The Exodus seminar
now there's like talk of some other
project which would bring us together
again so that would be great it'd be
it'd be a lot of fun but I'll I'll see
you before then I hope thank you on
Jonathan it's a pleasure thanks man